welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is
hisham azuz and today i'm really excited
to be joined by
amanda brandenburg who is the founding
principal
of opus lex partners amanda grew up and
lives in the states
she entered the world of recruitment in
2007
um where she joined the legal division
of robert half
after this she joined the beacon hill
staffing group where she worked for
nearly a decade
and in both these organizations amanda
accelerated
her recruitment career by going from
consultant all the way to division
director
and regional director in 2018
amanda founded her own recruitment
practice and for the last three years
she's been focused on growing that
business
and they are on a mission to support the
national legal sector by helping their
customers
create their very best body of work
amanda thank you for joining me thank
you so much for having me i'm excited to
be here
amazing so where we always like to start
on this show
is the uh million dollar question which
is
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think
make up a highly successful recruitment
consultant
well that's the that is the million
dollar question right and we could have
an entire podcast
um series that's what we're here to do i
think
um i think you know first of all i think
if we're talking about
big billers and people who have
staying power in this business
you know first of all i most of the ones
who i know
they're there's a scrappiness
about them right they just have that
fire in the belly um for whatever reason
and you know maybe they're competitive
or um you know maybe they have
something to prove maybe they have a
chip on their shoulder
who knows what it is that drives them
but i think they all tend to be pretty
scrappy
in terms of the big billers now
i think you know some of the more
intangibles
um that i think you know really
transcend this business
whether it's coaching other recruiters
or recruiting candidates
is really understanding you know
what motivates each individual whether
it's somebody
you know you're mentoring or developing
in your business
or someone you were trying to recruit
for a role what are their motivators
and then in turn really listening to
them
and um having a you know pretty good
sense of
[Music]
human psychology and maybe what might be
coming down the pipe
um or objections or
um you know roadblocks that might be
ahead so i guess a high level of
emotional intelligence
nice defined scrappy to me when you say
scrappy
i'm curious like what what what do you
mean how would you paint a picture for
me of someone that's
that you would maybe deem as a bit scrap
and i know it'll be different to each
person maybe but
i'm interested yeah i mean for me
i would consider myself scrappy in a lot
of ways and certainly more so probably
towards you know different parts of my
career but
um i think you know
they just wake up every day with
an itch that is never fully scratched if
i could
create that picture um there is a puzzle
that they're constantly working on and
it's never finished and
they are absolutely committed to um
completing you know whatever
whatever challenge that is but of course
it never is complete
i love that so obviously what what we're
here to um
unpack is your uh yeah nearly 15 years
in the staffing industry
right so obviously as i mentioned in the
introduction nearly now for the last
three years you've been focused on
building your own
business but let's just sort of start
and touch on
your time and when working for
other organizations so i guess
firstly just interested so the more i
understand
the nuances of the recruitment agency
landscape
in the u.s what i sort of seem to
continue to understand
and correct me if i'm wrong here is that
obviously
sort of going into like corporate
recruitment
so maybe in the sort of the lingo in the
uk would be like internal recruitment
right and that is like
a brilliant position to be in in terms
of
getting your medical stuff looked after
being on a really great salary
and these types of things so typically
in the uk
people will fall into the recruitment
industry and it's sort of part and
parcel that you start on like a lower
basic salary
but from the more i learn about the us
market that like for people so i've had
people on here that recruit
agency recruiters in the us etc that's
like a
real challenge because obviously you
could go down the path where like your
salary is
way higher than it would be in agency
recruitment et cetera so i guess where i
just wanted to start was
like what was your journey into
recruitment and
is that is that a fair observation as
i'm learning this that actually
if you went down the corporate
recruitment route there's a good chance
that your salary
would have been way higher than it was
in agency recruitment and
how was yeah how was that for you yeah
so
i've never worked in internal
recruitment or corporate corporate
recruitment as you're referring to it
so um that's nothing that's something
that's never
interested me at all um i
i think you know really big agency
recruiters
are a completely different person
generally
than internal corporate recruiters i
think they're different skill sets
they have different personalities and
they're motivated by very different
things
um so yeah i mean are the base salaries
very different yeah i think they're
probably you know if you're
an internal recruiter somewhere the base
salary is probably double of what it is
as an agency recruiter
um but of course the you know runway
or projections for your overall earnings
is significantly higher of course in an
agency
so yeah you certainly have to have an
appetite for risk
um and an excitement around risk so how
how did how did sort of amanda in 2003
like obviously you so from what i can
see you graduated in 2003
and you found yourself working for
robert half in 2007.
so i guess where i just wanted to start
i was just interested in like how did
amanda come about
working in recruitment like how is there
a story there how did you fall into it
was it intentional like what how did you
get into recruitment
so yes there's definitely a story there
it was not intentional
fell into it probably like most of
everyone else yeah you on your podcast i
imagine
i don't think anyone of course sets out
to be a recruiter in college
but it is interesting um
so i studied english literature and
philosophy in college
and you know unless you're going to
enter academia
there's not really a whole lot um you
know
on the outset that you're going to do
with those skulls i think they're
actually great skills that have served
me well but
i always thought that i might want to go
to law school that was in the back of my
mind
however the summer before i graduated i
went out to los angeles and did an
internship
with a talent and literary agency so
yeah in hollywood so placing actors
writers producers directors
and just absolutely fell in love with
that business
and um actually the owner of that agency
i remember said very clearly you know
we're nothing more than an employment
agency right
and the product is just you know really
exciting and you know sort of sexy but
at the end of the day they are just
placing you know these creatives and
jobs and so i love that business
and after graduation went back out to
los angeles and then entered an agent
training program
where i was for about three years in
that system and what i realized there
was that
um a lot of the agents had law degrees
so again kind of going back to that
scrappy thing what i learned from that
is that they weren't splitting their
commissions with
um they weren't explaining their
commissions at all with entertainment
lawyers
like many others were so you know after
i had been there for a few years and was
a bit tired and in a great amount of
debt
as well after living in los angeles on
my own and
um i thought well i'll go back home
to atlanta where i'm from and take the
lsat
the tests required for law school here
in the states and
apply to law school but then my whole
intention was to always go back to los
angeles and re-enter that business
so came here did that and worked at a
couple of law firms while i was going
through that process and just did not
enjoy working at law firms at all um
you know cliche story ended up you know
meeting a guy who would just graduate
from law school here
and did not want to move to los angeles
and you know one thing led to another
and then i
i just thought everyone kept saying you
should really look at a career in sales
and i didn't really
i never knew anyone who had a career in
sales i didn't know what those
jobs meant what sort of job that was
so i actually my first job in sales
was um selling shoes
and bags at ferragamo yeah
is a luxury um italian retailer
um known for uh you know exquisite shoes
and handbags and so did that and did
did really well on it and so i sort of
learned you know after doing that for a
year that
i did have the ability you know in terms
of business development
and human basic human human interaction
to build up rapport
and but of course i was you know getting
older my husband was
our boyfriend at the time was you know
gainfully employed as a lawyer and was
like all right when are you going to
get a real job here so um
and it was clear that i wasn't going
back to los angeles at that point and so
i answered an ad and again i still had
all this
this debt from la that i really needed
to kind of clear up
um before i got married and so answered
an
ad with robert half looking for somebody
with
legal experience and sales experience so
somehow some way
yeah my wayward path led me to that spot
and you know really when i took that job
i thought i'm going to do this maybe for
a year
and see if i can make some money and
then i'll kind of like regroup
and here we are then here we are yeah
yeah so
love that great story so i guess i guess
all i want to know from you then and
then
what i'm keen to just sort of find out
from you is i guess some of the sort of
key learns
you've experienced in progressing
getting to director level which a lot of
recruiters aspire to
but always interested because i'm sure
um
you would i guess this would be part of
the story that you would tell people
maybe when hiring for your own business
but obviously very early on in your
recruitment career can be
probably the most difficult and
challenging part of your career
there's so much to learn you're maybe
building out a patch etc so
always interested to hear like what was
your first year
in recruitment like was it difficult did
you find it quite easy actually because
of the
sort of story the journey that you went
on like how would you describe your
first year
well let's see so i think i started at
robert half in june
of 2007
okay perfect um and
you know at that point the economy was
really strong
there was a lot of activity and then of
course
in september 2008 um you know
lehman brothers fell here and we started
the great recession so um
that was a pretty interesting year in
that same
time span i also at the time got engaged
and then got
married in that same year and then i
think maybe
three or four months into working at
robert half
they promoted me to division director
which was probably you know a terrible
idea
um at the time for on their part so
you know i say that to say there was a
lot to learn because i had
no management experience whatsoever i
was new to this business um
now i'm supposed to hire develop lead
you know and sometimes fire people and i
i had no idea what i was doing
so it was i think we were in a recession
um so it's an interesting year i think
it's important to
point out that you know my time there
and
for probably the first 10 years of my
career i was exclusively a contract
producer
so didn't really do any direct hire
permanent placements
um which you know i think was an
interesting place to be in especially in
the recession with so many people
unemployed
um it was very difficult of course to
take those calls
from candidates who had lost their jobs
and were
losing their homes um but it also was
extremely rewarding when you
could call someone and say you know i
have you i have a job for you it starts
tomorrow
you know be ready and be there and they
were just elated that you know
now they had some extra money to to feed
their kids i mean it was a really
desperate situation
at that point yeah so it seems like you
were thrown completely in the deep end
then like a lot of
people are early on in their recruitment
career so
okay i'm fascinated by this so end
up having to yeah manage lead produce
yourself
as you said thanks for sharing that
content so before
you start your own recruitment business
is that right you you've always been
doing contract placements
in law is that right is what you end up
there for the majority of my time
yeah so um not necessarily exclusively
but most of my you know earlier
experiences around
contract producing and business
development in the contracts
attorney space specifically contract
return space okay amazing
so what i'm interested to hear from you
then so from what i can see
work to rob a half year in any two and a
half years then you join beacon hill
staff and groups i'm assuming by that
point you're like right i'm really
actually motivated to give recruitment a
real go
and i'm assuming you felt like you could
actually build something
here that maybe i guess you didn't
realize was an opportunity for you
um and i guess i'm just keen to hear so
most recruiters that will listen to this
podcast are will be people that
yeah have big aspirations want to be the
biggest producer within their business
or want to get to that sort of director
level they want to progress
so i'm just always interested and i
always ask this question like why
as i'm sure um you'll know recruitment's
a competitive landscape not only
externally but also internally
yeah so why obviously it seems like a
few different factors as to why you got
that promotion in robert half but i
guess i'm interested at beacon hill
because you worked there for a long
period of time
like why why do you think he was able to
be the person that got the promotion
opportunities over the the people around
you or the people next to you that
most likely would have liked those
opportunities as well of interest what
do you think you did differently
that's a great question i mean i think
when i was younger at robert half
um i had a i had two really
fantastic leaders um andy and amy if
you're out there
listening but um you know i never
i was listening to some of your earlier
episodes and talking about this question
and how do people progress to these
leadership roles and some people seem to
like really
know that's what they want to do and
they want to manage people
i've never really had an interest in
managing people
um i still don't know i think i still
don't have an interest in managing
you know i have my own company now which
is really uh quite ironic probably
but um i didn't ask for any of those
roles
um interesting so yeah
so i think you know in the early days at
robert half
i probably i think my boss used to tell
me there that i could probably outwork
anyone
you know i maybe wasn't the smartest or
i don't know you know didn't have
you know so maybe something that the
next person had but i had an
extraordinary work ethic
um and at that point too i was younger i
was you know
single and i have three children now of
course so life is a bit different
but um you know i was really committed
to it and i think for me
um i i was sort of shocked
as to the opportunity i had been given
um and the earning potential that was
available to me
and you know to this day um
you know i have a a life and a lifestyle
that
i never really would have planned on for
myself
or or even really dreamed of so i think
i always just felt a tremendous sense of
gratitude there
um and just worked really hard it was
it was recognized um i
took direction while i was very engaged
and interested in my job and how i could
do better
um how i could become a better manager
become a better biller
and the other thing i think is that i've
always had for better or worse really
close relationships with anyone i've
worked with and probably to a fault my
husband always says you know you don't
need to be
friends with everyone you work with but
i can't help it
so i think there was probably you know a
natural
internal politicking that happened um
with
those organizations because i i always
felt extremely close to everyone i
worked with
yeah look i think that there's a
important
sort of takeaway there where like yeah
it like it is important to build
relationships internally if
you want to yeah progress and get the
opportunities i think that's
i think sometimes people could miss that
um i think a lot of people can just put
in the work and then expect it
and without maybe building those
opportunities and building those
relationships
but i guess it seems like then did you
end up
obviously yeah all of those things but
was part of it that you were someone
that did perform well like would you
typically a top producer
and obviously here all the time man may
not have heard of it on this podcast but
it's really
a really common thing that people talk
about in the recruitment industry is
that like top
top producers don't necessarily make top
managers yeah
and i i was a top producer um and i
i again when i say that they made me the
director
you know three months in i don't know
that was a good decision on their part
um i think i've certainly learned a lot
about management
and development and growing a team and
mentoring a team
you know over the past 15 years that
i've been doing it
but i certainly you know didn't come
into any of those roles with any true
management experience training you know
and it probably frankly wasn't fair to
the people
who worked for me yeah yeah right yeah
so let's let's talk about that let's
talk about that because
i know there'll be a lot of people
listening i know that journey that
you've been through and it seems like
you're still on
like is one it can be really painful for
people and they have to learn a lot of
the things the hard way right
so i guess what i'm talking about is
what you're just saying there where like
yeah you didn't have management
experience but you was a top performer
you was working hard
they probably for amanda could make it
work she'll she'll make her team work
and she'll work out etc but
i guess maybe what what were the couple
of things that you really had to learn
the hard way would you say on that
leadership path that
if anyone listening to this is early on
in that sort of
billing producing but also now leading
managing
mentoring path that maybe you could give
them that you had to learn
the hard way out of interest well
first of all i want to say i think
different companies have different
cultures
obviously and so within that they have
different goals and frameworks in which
you can manage
um i think in some of these very large
shops that are very revenue driven
especially if they're a public company
they have a responsibility to their
shareholders
you don't have a lot of flexibility in
terms of how you manage
um so there's that so i've learned
lots of different styles depending on
the environment in which i found myself
but i think you know by and large you
have to actually care about
the person you're working with and
developing them and you
really need to want them to succeed in a
genuine way and they need to know that
they need to know that they have your
back or that you have their back rather
um and that they're your biggest
cheerleader
and um and you know and then figure out
what motivates them
and then keep that in front of them
every single day
that that's what they're working towards
and celebrate
you know catch them doing a great job
right
and celebrate it every single time but
um you know my most successful teams
we had a really strong camaraderie we
were friends
again i don't i don't know if that's a
good thing or not
but um we were and
i think the culture is so important and
i also think in the past 15 years of
course
you know i can only speak for my own
organization and those in which i've
worked but i think
recruitment has probably evolved a lot
from sort of the
extremely intensive kpi driven
environment
um where we're all wearing suits and
standing at whiteboards at 7 45 every
morning
too much more you know
i don't know i should say just you know
kinder experience maybe
yeah sure so um that's been really great
too
to have that what about what about
specific i guess i'm just trying to get
a bit of granular here
that comes up a lot what you said like
really like really understand
your people's motivations and and once
you actually really understand that then
that's you can really use that like you
said put it in front of them every day i
really like the way that you put that
i guess a typical challenge that i
always hear that people
want advice on is how what was amanda's
journey like when you had to produce
you had to hit certain numbers but he
was also responsible for
the team's numbers as well so there's
this sort of i guess
challenge of like manage your own
performance managing other people's
performance but you know you have to
support them but then you might get
frustrated because then your performance
might dip
like what was your journey with that did
you have to i guess get really good at
communicating times where amanda's got
to be locked in and focus and not be
distracted
i don't know what was just out of
interest was that a challenge that you
faced
sure i i think in all those sort of
billing manager roles if you want to
call them that that's there's
always certainly a time management
component but i think
to whatever extent and maybe this is
sort of easier on
i don't know maybe i've just been lucky
in terms of the situations that i've had
my particular clients or my
my particular book of business to
whatever extent
you can involve those people in your
goals
you are really accomplishing a lot um
you know at the same time right so yeah
um you're including them
in everything that you're doing and
you're making your goals their goals
and vice versa so you know you can be
doing your job as a producer but also
mentoring them by example
and you know not like putting people on
the email cc them i mean
i think we have such a strange culture
um
you know within so many recruitment
firms of
just being overly protective or
territorial about things
and i think that's absolutely the wrong
way to go about it so the sense that you
can
involve your team into the greater
mission whether it's you know
company or office or your own book of
business but also
mentor them and let them be a part of
everything it is that you're doing
if you feel that you do a good job at it
of course whether it's being on calls
coming to client meetings
copying them on emails listening to
their calls and you know
giving them feedback i think you can
incorporate a lot of that stuff in the
day-to-day
okay nice so i want to talk about your
your journey in building your own
recruitment business
so i guess just to sort of tie this
together what
so for people listening to early on in
their recruitment career the question i
have for you
to sort of try and get you to share i
guess
um advice to those types of people
um if you could go back and sort of
speak to amanda
in 2007 know what you know now what
advice would you give her do you think
to
sort of that you think would give her an
even better chance of maximizing the
opportunity and
career sort of opportunity that she was
about to embark on
what would you say to her do you think
it's a great question
um i think i would say to myself
that you know you're just as good as
anyone else here
um and there are so many different
styles and personalities
that i think you know in many
environments we kind of only allow for
one which tends to be
you know loud and maybe a bit abrasive
and you know
i know something that you're very
interested in you know maybe
stereotypically very male
um so i think letting myself
be myself truly um is something that i
would certainly say
and i think the other advice that i give
to recruiters just starting out is
you know half of this is staying in the
game
every day year after year um
you know i know some recruiters who i've
worked with over the years who
you know by and large are you know
maybe average to above average
recruiters probably but
they've been in it for you know 20 years
and
they the staying power is you know
hugely impactful
after a number of years and they're
making a great living and people like
them they have great clients and they
enjoy what they do
so there's a lot to show up exactly
and you have to do that every day you
know week after week
month after month year after year but
it's a compound effect
indeed i think that's yeah okay so let's
let's sort of switch this up again then
so started
your own recruitment business 2018 so
just to sort of paint a picture
um one is that a business that you
started by yourself
wasn't co-founded cool um and then just
to paint the picture where you are now
and then we'll sort of unpack it
from what i gathered two things that i
noticed so are you a business that's
under
10 heads yes i saw online amazing
and what i also saw which i found
interesting is you're an all woman
business as well
we are yes i don't know that we will
stay that way forever
but currently we are yeah just found
that interesting
yeah how many of you are there uh five
of us
five years awesome okay and um
yeah so obviously coming up towards
going towards your like three years in
business basically and then did you in
terms of the markets and the world that
you
sort of recruit support is it then sort
of still the law
law world obviously but have you then
transitioned to more permanent
hires or is it still contract or is it
both it's both
um and i think i would tell anyone who's
interested in starting a business
or looking at their business there is a
lot of value
in having both um having done this now
for a couple of decades you see markets
up and flow
and you see the unemployment rate go up
which is when it's really great to have
a contract business and you see
it go down which is when it's really
great to have a perm business
so to be able to have that flexibility
really gives you a lot of options and a
lot more financial stability
okay so talk to me about and i always
sort of frame out this because i i think
it's true
but like so i'm sure so many people in
your
time when you was employed would have
said to you ah
like i know one day i'll start my own
recruitment practice
like i'm making all this money for
robert half or whatever like imagine if
i was making that for myself
so like talk to me about like how why
was amanda able to take that first step
that so many people don't like what
maybe the confidence people said that to
me for years they asked me that question
would you ever go out on your own
and my answer was always a hard no
okay so
i um when i left robert half again i was
recruited away during the recession
to open an office um
for for beacon hell and so i had the
experience of
building something building a brand
building a team
and you know after nearly a decade
it was it was built um and
it it functioned really well and
i um personally just felt
that there wasn't much left for me in
terms of
you know satisfying my own internal
or intellectual curiosity and
really wanted to go build something else
and the
proposition of just continuing to open
you know offices for somebody else and
put
put a team there did not really excite
me um
at the point of time i was there in my
life so
you know i wanted to own something that
was mine i wanted to
make my own rules establish my own
culture
create my own brand and i in in it's
in exceedingly difficult it was
exceedingly difficult to start it's
probably even harder you know day to day
now that it's like up and running
and profitable it's like you have even
bigger um
challenges to manage but i really needed
that
you know at the point of life i was then
to
remain engaged and excited about what i
was doing every day
that makes sense so did you have
children at this point when you started
the business
oh yes yes so um back to beacon hill
when i opened that office i was pregnant
newly pregnant with my first child
so i have had children you know for
most of my recruiting career at this
point my oldest child is 11 my youngest
child there are three of them my
youngest child is five
so yes all of my children at this point
were born and
um and you know are used to this
lifestyle in this business
love that so talk to me about so people
are interested in like what
i guess what has what have been some of
the sort of
most difficult challenges so far that
you didn't expect
out of interest in having your own shop
or starting your own recruitment
business
i think for me and i'm sure this is
probably different for
a lot of people for but for me it's
making like the day-to-day
decisions and all the things that you
need to think about
right like whether it's marketing or
your social media
or is it time to hire right now do you
want an office
um are we going to work in
you know this market or another
and you know being small i always say
this too
it really prioritizes or it forces you
to prioritize
your job orders and what you're going to
work on which i actually love because
you have to be so rigid and so strict
about
the business that you take and the
business you spend time working on
but it's a constant reprioritization
of sort of what's coming in what you're
pushing out
and just managing really day to day
which is completely different from
managing you know
relatively on autopilot with you know a
500 million dollar or
you know multi-billion dollar in the
case of robert half you know established
organization where you have a framework
because every day here we are
literally creating the framework um and
you kind of you know if you're like me
and you're very analytical
and you really want to get it right
you're constantly questioning yourself
is this right is this the best past you
know my because it's it's very it's a
lonely experience and there aren't a lot
of other people that you can really look
to
who've done this sure so
i want to get sort of practical with you
if that's okay i'll
get a bit in the detail so obviously
what i'm keen just because you said it's
something that you love
and speaking to a lot of recruiters at
the moment who will tell you that
they're really busy
they have loads of job orders on one of
their biggest challenges what you're
just
talking about there prioritization like
should i
should i definitely work on this job or
should i definitely work on that job
so i guess i know there's again nuances
here but if i say to you
what criteria do you sort of
work to or are you continuing to build
or what are your non-negotiables when it
comes to
right i'm gonna definitely work on this
job order because of this
or because of x that's gonna make me
feel good about spending
two hours or four hours this week on
sourcing that job and
i feel like i'm gonna have a much better
chance of filling that job and
getting what i need to out of that
compared to the other job interested in
what your criteria looks like
sure so it does um and it's a question
that
i've been asked several times so um
first of all
we want to work for people we like and i
know that sounds like really basic
and maybe somewhat abstract but i i
promise you you will do a better job you
will have
more excited energy
around you know recruiting and sourcing
for orders where the hiring manager
your in-client is someone you like and
someone you feel
you need to deliver for um you know at
least for me and my team
that will kind of get us up every day
because we know that person is counting
on us so that's important
if you know you're just dredging through
and working on order for you know an
organization that you're not excited
about
or you know you know the role is like
going to turn over or it's going to be
really difficult
for that candidate it's just harder so i
think in the
in ranking them um liking the incline is
actually really important
you know to what's the client's value
proposition what's their standing in the
marketplace
do they have a strong reputation do they
have some challenges that need to be
addressed and you know that's not
necessarily a deal breaker and i think
if you have
a recruiter who is a true business
partner an ally for your organization
um you know they can overcome a lot of
those you know if you have
challenges around reputation or brand or
anything like that they can do that for
you and really speak to your specific
department
um as a hiring manager so there's that
also to you
are the clients expectations realistic
with
with what's going on in the marketplace
right now or are they
as we love to say in recruiting looking
for the purple squirrel or
the unicorn right like otherwise like
don't you know are there compensation
um allowances aligned with what the
market is bearing
and you know in terms of the skill set
are they realistic here
um and then you know finally
to be selfish but again this goes back
to your internal culture
motivation also just the ins and outs of
running a small business
what are the payment terms um are you
engaged are you retained are you
contingent and if so like when are you
gonna get paid
because um while i would like to say
that it doesn't really matter
it matters immensely when you're
financing the whole thing
yeah yeah sure i think it all upside
down yeah but i think also too
when you have fair payment terms the
relationship
just works better and
you feel more valued as a business
partner and
you know i think you're also usually
dealing with a more
educated consumer at that point when you
are working with clients who have
favorable payment terms so that's always
important in other areas
so talk okay great so talk to me about
what
what has been the most effective way for
amanda to win business
and we can keep it recent last six
twelve months like obviously yeah
spoken about producing a lot of the time
we just said about yeah really love
prioritization these things but like
what has enabled you to
always have the best chance of winning
clients working with
clients that you'd like like what's been
your most effective new business
strategy out of interest well i will say
i don't think i'm
you know i'm probably not the person to
ask about the last six or 12 months
because we just have a lot of
you know over a couple of decades you
have a book of business
and you have clients and a reputation so
i have a lot of incoming
passive business that comes i'm not out
there making cold calls generally
anymore but
um you know i think i think
generally speaking um
you know you have to kind of think
outside the box and really
really think about who you're going to
connect with so for example
um the biggest client that i've ever won
this was a contract client and they were
my client
um for over a decade and
produced millions and millions of
dollars in revenue
um before the agency i worked for then
you know that was me calling on
an ad by another agency
that just looked a little suspicious and
a little interesting to me
in doing a little bit of research and
calling around and using the connections
i had
in that organization it happened to be
one person i met at a conference five
months earlier
and asking really good questions and
then getting to that person but
once i got to the decision maker and i
think there's a actually a lot to learn
from this
the story which is why i'm spending time
telling you the story
um you know it wasn't like yeah sure
here's our
you know wad of business carry on it was
here is my most challenging you know job
order right now
or project that the other agency is not
not
doing a good job with i'm not going to
give you the easy stuff i'm going to
give you basically the crap work
and you need to take that crap work and
like
knock it out of the park and then ask
for more you know keep doing the crap
work as long
as you need to and then you know you
will absolutely earn the right to ask
for the good easier work
so that's a good lesson but aside from
that and
that relationship and other
relationships i've had i remember going
back to robert half when i was had my
director there
i we would you know make the call it was
like a very
rigid process right like you made the
call you sent a letter this is
antiquated you maybe wrote like a
handwritten note
and then it was like you had the meeting
at the
client's place of work and i would like
do all that and say okay now what
and um most
most recruiters especially junior
recruiters aren't able
to think about like forming the bigger
relationship and so
the next step was actually to befriend
that client you know like stop looking
for the business
and actually form a real relationship
with the person
and learn more about them and stop
asking for the business
just you know be with them understand
like
who they are what's challenging them you
know
in their day-to-day and again back to
showing up
keeps showing up but you've got to kind
of like change the script a little bit
from
sell sell sell sell get the business
if that makes sense yeah yeah what do we
need to change it to
yeah relationship
relationship right like you have to
build
a friendship and a bond and for people
who are doing this for the long haul
that will sustain you most of my best
clients are some of my best friends in
life as well now and of course they
started out as clients and
their lifelong friends who know about my
family my kids you know everything
that's going on
and they want to support me because they
care about me as a human being and vice
versa
yeah fair enough i like that i know
again it's a long game and
sometimes it can be quite hard to sort
of see that
when you're sort of building out your
desk building out your market but
it's the relationships it's doing these
things keep showing up every day that
it'll pay dividends
later down the track and so it seems
like you've really benefited from that
when
building your own business because you
had this yeah all these relationships
you built up that
you can lean on and these things so i
guess talk to me about what's your
journey been like in
hiring for your own recruitment business
then like
what mistakes have you made have you
found it difficult what's that been like
out of interest
i think it's very difficult um to know
when to hire um who to hire
where in what capacity um
because again when you're when you're
forming a startup
you're you know this is not a large
conglomerate so you also don't have all
the other things so
you know whereas maybe you were used to
having
a marketing department or an hr
department or
an administrative assistant and you
really as a billing manager only hired
recruiters
well now you only have a certain number
of resources to work with
dollars in my case and um
you know you have to figure out what is
going to have the biggest impact on the
business
right now with the resources that you
have available and it's not always
necessarily hiring more recruiters
and then if you do hire more recruiters
then it's are you hiring someone with a
book of business
um and does that create a new
problem so to speak so if you bring
somebody in with a lot of business who's
used to developing business but maybe
you know is also accustomed to having
people source for them
do you need to turn around and then hire
another sourcer
um so maybe now you're hiring two people
are you training people from the start
and what does that look like so you know
that has been extremely challenging for
me just in my own head
having said all of that we have a
fantastic team here
that's been together you know for most
of these three years
and they have come to us with a variety
of backgrounds
and experience levels and motivations
for their own life and
you know different reasons for doing
this so i think
one thing that i've learned just over
the years and something that i'm really
proud of for our agency
is that we're not just one size fits all
we're not hiring you know like
this is the sales person this is the
this is the mode this is the profile and
that's it um
we're really looking at the organization
for a more holistic approach hiring
people
with different strengths different
styles
and with each hire that we make it's
not like is this person in a vacuum you
know exceptional and do we want them
it's how do they fit into our existing
organization
um and will that benefit our our
delicate
and tiny ecosystem or disrupted in some
way
have you got any better at recognizing
hiring triggers at all
because you are very much like working
out as you go and i'm
like did you say to yourself right i'm
going to get six to 12 months worth of
revenue in the bank or if i was to hire
someone they'd be covered for at least
six months like how
have you ended up you said that you like
analytics and stuff like that have you
ended up
i don't know i know you're still on the
journey but out of interest if you've
got a better
going right so if we hit if we're in
around here if we've got this amount of
job orders
like our sort of um interview to
placement ratios around this
then we should hopefully be in a good
spot to hire it be a good time to bring
someone on to deliver i don't know have
you got any better at that of interest
yeah i think you know like really
quickly when you need to hire
um we're in that spot now that we
absolutely need to hire
so anyways
is that because you're what you have a
lot of opportunities like good
quality jobs that you like you know that
you
you could deliver is that is that what
it is that what it is exactly
so there's a lot of opportunity that
we're currently missing
because we just don't have the bandwidth
to support it at the level that i wish
we could we need more
um you know eyes on the market and more
phones being dialed
outbound for recruiting purposes to
candidates
so that's our current situation and in
terms of like knowing when
um you know this is a roller coaster and
for anyone
who's considering starting their own
business and actually growing a business
not just
you know being a solo recruiter and
having a lifestyle business but really
developing a true
agency with that goal in mind i mean
it's hard it's it's hard to
figure out a way to finance it um
recruitment is not
um an industry that banks
um are really big fans of especially as
startups so
you do have to or at least in my case
you kind of have to bootstrap it
and make it work so it's a roller
coaster in terms of revenue
and timing and if you're like me i'm
very conservative and i want to like you
know squeak it out until the last minute
until
it's very apparent that we are you know
walking away from revenue which is where
we are now but i think a lot of people
are probably in that
situation since we're um all so busy
right now
okay so before we finish i just want to
get your
honest thoughts on a couple of things so
what i wanted to ask you was i think i
mentioned this to you when we last spoke
but
um i would say most progressive
recruitment businesses pre-covered
had sort of us on their business plan
and i think that's definitely shifted
again in the last sort of six or 12
months
or businesses have really recognized the
um
positives that come with like
diversifying their business
and not just only doing business in the
uk etc so i guess i just wanted your
honest thoughts and you may be able to
add context on this or not but like
where do you think us brits need to like
really understand
around the u.s market the nuances of
doing business in the us
from a recruitment perspective that um
you think will give us a better chance
of being successful is my question
that my sentence that's a great question
it does make sense
um i don't know if i'm the best person
to answer that but i think
at its core um
[Music]
you know americans are are very
different i have learned in terms of our
i think i told you i am um i'm part of a
sort of a um mastermind group
and most of the members in that group
are in the uk
and they're so polite
and they raise their hands
and wait you know for wait for someone
to call their name before they speak and
all these things and i'm like
oh my gosh like we gotta just just talk
just get it out
um so i think there are probably a lot
of like
stylistic nuances there that you know
americans are much more direct and
probably a bit louder and full of
personality so
i you could probably have again a whole
show just on that
how that fleshes out in in recruitment
agencies in the workplace
fair enough okay um and then i guess
the other question i had for you
something that i continue to learn is
that
in the uk the recruitment industry
doesn't have the best reputation
at all but what a lot of people share
when they go
start recruiting in the us is that it's
actually seen
as more of a professional profession and
it's got more respect and these things
why why do you think that is from your
opinion like out of interest
uh i have no idea i didn't know it was
seen as oh really a respectful
respectable profession in the u.s um
that's good to know
uh i'm not sure so much how it's
structured in the uk
in terms of you know differences there i
think
you know for any professional respect
that i do have um
at least speaking for me and those in
legal recruiting it's because we are
highly specialized
and we're respected as you know members
of the community of the legal community
or the law firm community or just being
a part of that
vertical um and you know we talk to and
work with really smart people all day
who all have law degrees and you know
are
well established and respected in their
careers so i think we enjoy
some of that um prestige i suppose but
i don't think my kids or you know my or
anyone is like oh my gosh my mom's a
recruiter it's like
so amazing yeah but like
for example if you were to go to a party
and like would you be embarrassed to say
i'm a recruiter
um i usually say it probably a little
different
but no um look i
you know it's interesting well if look
i'll tell you this in my family
so you know my myself i'm an only child
but you know
my husband my husband's family i'm the
only person
um with without a graduate degree i have
a bachelor's degree
um from a you know a state university
um but i would say
you know my family and my my children
and myself we have you know
the same or better lifestyles than many
people who have taken
you know different paths that are far
more
academically intensive or um expensive
so yeah yeah i just think because in the
uk
like people sometimes would be
embarrassed to say that they're a
recruiter and like or it gets like
an instant response of all god's like
one of them so i was just interested in
it's something that a lot of uk
recruiters pick up on but i think it
comes back to your point earlier on
on when people like your own husband
said you should go into a sales career
like that you wouldn't normally hear
that in in the uk
i feel like like that might be i think
it is changing but i think like a
sales career isn't like people just hate
to be sold to in the uk
like they just like so like sales is a
career
really like that's an actual career so
like the fact that someone really close
to you was
encouraging that i just feel like that's
that is an interesting nuance i think
that's different that i do here a lot
well i mean isn't that sort of the core
of you know america and the united
states that we're all here to
you know we were a scrappy country right
from you know from the uh story of
origin here
so yeah yeah i think we're all out for
the american dream and we're all
here to build something and yeah you're
right i mean i
i think at this point in my career i'm
very proud of my career and i'm very
proud to go into any party and say i own
a legal recruiting firm um i'm excited
what i have built um what i've done in
my career has you know not been easy and
i'm exceedingly proud of it but
i certainly understand and take your
point there
yeah yeah talk to me about and i feel
like i'm just trying to get information
out of you here so i hope you don't mind
but like
i'm just interested to hear like your
perspective on things basically which is
why i'm asking these questions i think
it can
hopefully yeah obviously the things that
i'm saying you're surprised and i'm
finally interested in what you're saying
but obviously america is so big
right so i guess from your point of view
and i know this is again nuanced to like
the legal world but like just interested
to hear like
what states do you think like are really
exciting
or are like like typically you would
hear uk people aren't going to be
recruiting in new york
or it might be obviously la previously
etc but
i'm i'm definitely hearing more and more
people talk about atlanta
for sure as a really sort of big growth
area for different sectors
hearing about um texas austin texas is
another big area
dallas etc so i was just curious to hear
from like
your point of view where do you think
some of the sort of exciting growth
opportunities are in different states
that maybe
some uk based people may not typically
think of
out of curiosity well i think when
you're evaluating any market
whether it's you know the states or
otherwise you have to balance
you know demand an opportunity with
competition
so whereas you can go to new york there
are going to be more jobs available for
you to work
on um the salaries are going to be
higher there of course
in terms of your your fee at the end of
the day but the competition in terms of
the number of recruiters
who are calling into those firms are you
know is fierce
if you go to a secondary you know i've
always lived in atlanta so i certainly
know the atlanta market very well
but you know even out even atlanta is
pretty established in a pretty large
market at this point but you go to a
you know more secondary or tertiary
market you're gonna have a lot less
competition
um and you know
you might do very well um in some of
those smaller markets but
yes i think austin of course and their
tech scene is amazing what they have
going on so i think that's a huge
opportunity
um i have always been a really big fan
fan
of houston texas um and found it to be
very exciting you
um you know again maybe a little less
crowded than the northeast
but northeast money as well so a bit
different
there um and i'm sure there are
certainly you know
outside of los angeles and san francisco
there's still probably a lot of
opportunity happening in california but
i would encourage anyone to
you know consider things from a more
regional
and national perspective rather than
just you know
one standalone market especially right
now with
remote work and people being so mobile
i'm very interested to see how
recruiting firms
structure territories going forward
um because i i think our candidate base
is is highly
opened up a lot more yeah cause like
whenever i speak also like
it was something that i've learned is
that american people it's like way more
normal to like commute quite a long way
exactly well yeah yeah it's a lot of fun
yeah that's
yes a lot oh yeah an hour and a half
that's like that's like a casual
commute or something like that but like
in the uk that would be like horrible
yeah well i wouldn't commute an hour and
a half personally but like you said
the remote pieces really opened it up
because yeah yeah
so interesting yeah and i you know too
with the way hiring managers are going
to be structured as well i think going
forward i was just on the phone before i
jumped on with you with someone who
manages a team in india
and you know now does it from his house
in atlanta and manages folks in the uk
as well so i think your hiring managers
are also
going to be very mobile so um
just like with us we might have a client
who sits in atlanta or sits in florida
but they manage you know something for
their firm
nationally or regionally and so that
takes us to
a variety of states and cities working
for them
so we've got a couple of quick file
questions for you okay
so first question is what do you think
is the most important
action or kpi that you feel contributes
to a recruiter's success
that's a great question
um i think probably
god i hate using this word
to pay homage to robert half i should
say um
[Music]
connects right and that was defined and
connected
yeah okay it was defined as a live phone
call
or um you know as time went on
um an email exchange i i'm old school
i still think if you really want to get
to know someone you need to
get on the phone with them or go meet
them in person you know now of course we
have online platforms like this so i
think that's really helpful over time
but i you know for the junior recruiters
out there listening
you're not going to build a brand or
reputation
year after year by emailing people or
doing like automated linkedin campaigns
it's a tool but it's not the way to do
this business yeah okay
nice what book have you read
if you don't read it could be audio book
podcast or whatever
that have you read or yeah consume that
has had the biggest
impact on you oh my gosh
um could be personal or professional
okay this is really hard do you read
i do i was an english major so oh yeah
sorry
i i did nothing but read in college
yeah yeah it's like it's like choosing
my favorite song or my favorite movie
for my favorite band i'm never good at
it because i like
um so many but okay i'll give you a
really weird one here
and this is like no one's probably ever
ever answered this
that's okay um but i read a lot of
uh william faulkner in college
and if anyone's ever read faulkner you
probably know how challenging it is
and um just what a like a mind trip that
is
so as i lay dying by william faulkner
okay interesting just go google and like
you'll just just take us you know
finally
yeah so it's just like just questioning
life and why we're here and stuff like
that
well more or less but i think also just
the art form
um of writing and sort of back to
talking about
you know studying english i and i in it
back as it relates to recruitment
the ability to communicate effectively
um you know ever in spoken word or
especially now in written word is
extremely powerful
so certainly enhance your writing skills
in any way that you can
well i've got two questions for you okay
i'll let you go this one's a bit more
a bit more playful bit more different
but like what
what did you spend your first biggest
commission paycheck
on
okay um
[Music]
first biggest well for the first several
years i really just
i paid off all my credit cards yeah
i got rid of my debt um and then i had a
bait well
i'll say this i in 2009 so about a year
and a half after
i started at robert half um
i bought a house and i was pregnant with
my first child and bought a house
um but i uh
to fast forward to to now um
i recently i've bought a vacation
property that i was really proud to buy
and really excited to do that which is
also an investment property
and um you know i just made a large
placement
several weeks ago and i've decided that
i'm buying a boat
i love that absolutely love that
so far final question is what is
the ultimate goal for your recruitment
career
or recruitment business sure
um you know i want to do this for as
long as
i'm happy doing this and so far i
haven't had too many days where i'm not
happy doing this so i'm not sure
where the end of that road is
um we do certainly want to grow
but not just for growth's sake sure
so i think our ultimate goal my goal is
to build this brand
but have it be truly authentic and for
people to know the people who
who are here and know what they're about
and let that become as big as
it possibly can in a true and authentic
way
love it amanda thank you so much for
joining me thanks for being so open and
honest
and um really excited to share this of
everyone and
uh also excited to see how the business
grows and you're gonna have to um make
sure you get a picture of the old
boat on linkedin you get that but thank
you so much for coming on
thank you so much for having me